hey there folks it's Friday and it's
time for another movie retrospective
yeah this is good there's another
Lovecraft one yeah we're going Lovecraft
Hannon look dudes I did the whole theme
and everything look Cthulhu tequila I
think you've been what you know yeah
it's even like you know has to do with
the show and everything you and your
Kela although you know not today we got
to get this over today and actually I
don't have a cocktail there's that black
cop yeah I was using up the rest of the
coffee that was Jade schedules jammed we
got to get this new book out and she's
got a bunch of orders packing Oh for a
graphic design so we got to go ahead and
knock this one out yeah yeah this is a
good movie though it's by the same
company that did Dagon this seems to be
in it no it's not okay well it has
Geoffrey Calmes in it yeah this is
actually it's a French American
co-production okay and it was made in
1993 and it's usually just called
Necronomicon although it has some other
alternate titles like with little colon
at then like Necronomicon Book of the
Dead or yeah Necronomicon to hell and
back or HP Lovecraft's Necronomicon but
it's the same movie yeah and it's a hard
to find movie that I can only find like
blu-ray and DVD bootlegs coming out of
Greece yeah we really this was not this
really a big right I don't know and
you're saying it's an anthology movie um
so it's gonna be it's like it has like a
wraparound story called the library
it has Jeffrey Combs in weird makeup
that made and he is actually playing HP
Latex playing up guys right and the
whole that whole sequences it's very
funny like seeing he almost looks like
bruce campbell yeah yeah one you don't
like the weird nose and the chin
Ottomans yeah it's pretty creepy but
yeah so he plays HP Lovecraft and the
whole wrap around story is that he has
discovered that dynamic connected on the
neck that the real neck Rubicon is in
this library presumably in Providence
cuz that's Neely right ever lived and
the first part is said in the 30s so he
actually goes to this library and kind
of he's not I don't think he's like
intending to steal it but he just wants
to read it yet to inspire him to write
these uh these stories that he's gonna
tell you he is he's right yeah so that's
he's reading through the Necronomicon
and then it's like three different
stories yeah and it's it's like it's not
a normal library it's like a cult
library or a cult library inside of an
of a temple manned by a bunch of
Egyptian cultists yeah yeah and they're
they're like I don't know if there's a
Cthulhu cult there's someone I they're
not humans are they I don't think they
were no no because he took his skin off
yes and so they'd be a generally humans
don't do that they may have been a they
may have been old ones or something yeah
just like in he in monkey suits abroad
yeah yeah he steals keys and he's like
looking through the thing and so they
show him like writing the beginning of
each door like he was inspired by the
Necronomicon to write this particular
story yeah it's three stories yeah and
in the wraparound story they're pretty
good stories the three stories are now
if you're a fan of Lovecraft's work
these are pretty loose adaptations yeah
um the first one is called the drowned
and it's ostensibly based on round the
rats in the wall even though it kind of
has some elements of shadow of wrens
mouth it kind of has some elements of
mate called Cthulhu and a couple of
other stories too and it kind of has to
do with this guy that comes back he gets
called back to take over this really old
like falling apart hotel that belonged
to one of his ancestors and he finds all
his ancestors papers and it turned out
that the ancestor who was played by
what's that dude's name richard lynch
well you Mystery Science Theater fans
out there
richard lynch was also in the very very
terrible but also kind of wonderful 1995
movie werewolf or war wolf want to say
it's a weird girl that was one of the
best MST episodes ever so if you haven't
seen it you should go look it up because
that movie is just hysterical but he's
in this and he plays the ancestor and
evidently I don't know like I'm not real
clear on what he was a shipwreck and he
didn't save his wife and kid or
something like that and they died and he
brings them back and so there's kind of
like a thing where you know the modern
guy
is calling back to the home like you
know calling back one of his his
girlfriend or his wife or whoever who he
accidentally killed the same kind of way
yeah the second story is actually one
that there was they had a night remember
night gallery night gala
there was a night gallery adaptation of
it was called cool air oh they're cool
air cool air I've got a guy who you know
he seemed to be older than then he
should have been he should have been a
hundred something years old and he was
built this really crude air conditioning
system this is like back in the 1830 or
may have been early nineteen there's
been a long time have seen it and DAC
breaks but you find out that he had
preserved himself well that was actually
based on an HP Lovecraft short story and
they tell a version of that story in
this one it's pretty good too and David
were isn't it right and I love David
Warner he's good and everything yeah
about how to prolong life and bring the
dead back to life using some kind of
essential salts they don't really you
know as well HP Lovecraft type
technology this is L chemical type yeah
and this one the second one it's weird
because they didn't name them I guess
because they weren't going to that
faithfully adopt them so they didn't
give them the same names as the stories
I just kind of reminisce yeah the first
one was just called the Drowned and the
second one was called the cold even
though it's mostly based on cool air
right and now the third story was based
on whispers in the dark or so they say
like some people's thought yeah it's not
real it's not really close um actually
it almost seems more like there was one
called the nameless city I think that
was sort of close to this but almost
like a vision of Hell type of thing and
this one is probably the hallucination
out of all of them and it's also by far
the goriest right this like I said came
out in the early 90s and if you're into
gore Tom Savini did like supervise most
of the effects on this and they are very
good yeah it's pretty disturbing the
very last one yeah so they're super
super gory and the last ones really
the goriest one but it's also like I
said the loosest adaptation yeah all
this loose adaptation stuff that's
actually not a big deal because really
that that's actually that was part of
the tradition of Lovecraftian lore
Lovecraft kind of encouraged other
people to kind of expand on his mythos
and you can't really put an HP Lovecraft
story most of them you can't they're not
movable not nothing really happens in
its all mood most of them and when
something does happen it's it's so vague
like in in most year Lovecraft stories
there aren't any real action scenes it's
kind of like something out of the old
original book Dracula worth like a
series of reports or a series of letters
tell the story you know Lovecraft had a
pretty baroque writing style it's kind
of like I don't know well in the days
it's like from it's not even a he died
almost he's born 100 years ago but he
was like something from 200 years ago
really yeah he was he was a much he kind
of like romanticized things much earlier
than even he was born and he was from
like the beginning of the toy yeah he
was kind of kind of an Asperger's type
guy he was kind of he was weird
he didn't have any social skills really
he was sheltered kind of his mother
didn't really show him any affection
really he wasn't the kind of guy he
really could you know get laid per se he
wasn't until much later later and you
know he he grew up but it took him a
long time to grow up he really didn't
become a full-fledged man to leave his
pride in his 40s and like I said I've
and like you said I think it's Oh God
yeah it's it's kind of hard to adapt a
lot of his stuff to film because so much
of it has to do with subjective
experience like so much of it is in the
first person and it's all from the
narrator's point of view and how they
feel about things and that's like really
hard to show on screen right um in a
story it works really well because he's
very good at like building up atmosphere
and building up Moo
and stuff like that but you know unless
you're gonna go the whole tentacle
monsters route there's really not a lot
to show because a lot of his work has to
do with what's unknown it's like we
can't show it it'll make it'll drive you
mad and all this other guy stuff so they
can't show it so I do see why they do
that type of thing where they're just
like okay we're just gonna do like a
loose adaptation or they're gonna do
something that's Lovecraftian like like
in the mouth of madness was yeah like
the thing is kind of actually the the
from what I remember reading the only
the only story that I thought was like a
modern book that told a modern tale was
out at the mountains of madness yeah
that was like a modern horror tale kinda
yeah kind of almost like the thing yeah
it was very similar I think that's where
the thing or they might have ripped that
off right now I mean and you know that
was like fun based on to think rather
based on a book yeah when you really
look at the thing at least John
Carpenter's version of the thing which
is kind of like bass also based on who
goes there
yeah John Carpenter's interpretation of
the thing was a shag off yeah which you
know any we know that carpenter read
Lovecraft so he's going like okay yeah
my thing is ash a goth yeah you know so
like I said sometimes the best Lovecraft
adaptations aren't actual directions at
all no there's a fan fiction fan I mean
cuz look at like reanimate ER and from
beyond itself like that which are
loosely based loosely based you know
nominally Lovecraft adaptations but you
know they took it in a different
direction and they're very good I think
probably the closest one that's the best
one is Dagon which we've already done
that is that is very good at capturing
the atmosphere of what he's talking
about he's talking about like and it has
that whole drippy fishy kind of yeah
[ __ ] and and everything I like seafood
yeah they didn't like so you've really
had some problems yeah now this this
movie here like I said it's hard to find
you can watch it for free kinda on
dailymotion you can see the first hour
of it in HD it looks really good alright
and then this part two of its missing
they took it down
then you can you can also watch the full
version in HD on YouTube the problem is
the top of the screen in the bottom of
screen to cut out a little bit you can
still watch it but it's not full you're
gonna miss a green you know so I Connor
wood if you want unless you want to
spring 20 bucks to see the movie or to
buy that the blu-ray or the DVD you
might you might be able to rent it on
Amazon you probably can't you might give
a check and you know most of that kind
of [ __ ] you can get on streaming oh yeah
but it's worth seeing the movie it's
kind of like along the lines John
Carpenter's of body bags or maybe tails
McRib yeah it's a Lovecraftian version I
want to say it's like I love anthology
movies generally I mean see you know
they're mixed bag usually but I mean
sometimes there's you know one segment
in there that's like really good and
kind of makes up for the other ones I'm
gonna place this one I don't think it's
as good as like Creepshow which we
definitely have to do know about but
it's for sure better than cats I um
which I also actually kind of liked and
I would put it around the same tier as
body bags it's yeah it's kind of the
same vibe it's not quite as mainstream
well it's not quite as wacky yes as him
like you know I don't mind I was kinda I
was wacky and mainstream it had kind of
yet had kind of a black humor tales from
there Necronomicon does have a true love
crafting 5 - some of it does some of it
yeah I'm gonna say here's what I'm gonna
say the first segment the Drowned which
was actually directed by christophe gans
the french director who did the
brotherhood of the wolf which was
actually a really good cult werewolf
movie that if you haven't seen that you
should probably go see the X it's really
good that I'm gonna say has the most
Lovecraftian vibe yeah it has like the
gold gothic crumbling castle it has kind
of a Cthulhu type monster yeah it has
that kind of as a ghost story filled
aesthetic to it yet so I'm gonna say
that's the most Lovecraftian the second
one the cold with David Warner that was
based on cool air is probably the most
faithful the most faithful adaptation of
the story that it was supposedly based
on and I think it's the best segment
as far as writing acting suspense as far
as that kind of thing goes it has some
gore in it which is really entertaining
and it's just a good story it's like a
mystery story like a story within a
story so I think that's kind of the best
segment the last segment that's actually
my favorite one she doesn't like yeah
the last segment I think is the weakest
just because for sure it's the goriest
it's the most fun it's action for this
action horror and it's real disturbing
it was directed by Brian jasna who
obviously worked on reanimate ER and
from beyond yeah various other things
that also worked on okay yeah I thought
the whole movie was done by that guy he
just did like the last of the last part
actually the second the second one the
second segment with David Warner I was
actually directed by a Japanese
directors to Sookie koneko who actually
did the 1995 Gamera movie
oh it was actually decent no really
likes that but uh yeah so he did the
second one but the third one it's it's
the goriest I also think it's the least
Lovecraft in and it doesn't seem it
doesn't make a whole lot of sense like
it doesn't have a lot of plot it's it's
all visuals but you know what Lovecraft
sometimes doesn't there's no real plot
line to a lot of Lovecraft nothing I'm
gonna say it is Lovecraftian it's just
that the delivery is very modern it is
yeah it's like a modern right but that
was still the kind of [ __ ] that
Lovecraft was talking about yeah it's
just that he this has told you in a very
modern setting and it's taking place in
in what made 90s yeah it was yes so the
delivery was pretty contemporary but
that's still kind of the idea things
living down in caves yeah you know and I
guess they're aliens it's not really
explained aliens are old one they're
aliens and they seem to want to be able
to kind of crossbreed with humans so
they can live a better life but you got
to get rid of your body they're gonna
they're gonna eat your body I'm not a
spoiler which was kind of which yeah
kind of like whispering the kinda like
whisper in the dark right so yeah where
they were taken out to pop it out your
brain popping out to Brian and it's
pretty disturbed I have to say that the
best gag other than other than the
melting gag in the second one like the
melting the in the third segment which
is called whispers the the brain-dead
with the guy without you know what I
mean where they share the bed yeah yeah
don't matter
don't know I'm not that's actually my
favorite that's my rig at the home baby
but overall like I said I really like
this movie I like anthology movies it's
a little uneven like all I'm not as good
as dead guy it's not okay yeah it's not
as good as day all par with reanimate ER
and from beyond but different it's an
anthology kind of like body bags but I
would say it's on par with not as
classic yeah I would say I would say it
was the weakest out of the three but
it's there yeah it's good enough well
like I said you know if if you're into
Lovecraft and you don't mind like some
liberties being taken or you're more
into like Lovecraftian type of stuff
yeah then probably you will get into
this if you're not gonna be - yeah I
don't worry about that
I don't worry about the liberties
because every movie with Lovecraft's
name on it many liberties were taken you
have to yeah that's the thing is because
of their literature yeah and Lovecraft
encouraged that you know Lovecraft kind
of had a little cult of admirers and
fans that followed him in his lifetime
and they wrote their own spin and he
added to the to his mythos and he he
encouraged it you know you could do it
just as you know and they all rated it
you know you know that's what dr. price
does he writes you know Lovecraft stop
metal that we saw him on one of the
documentaries of that we yeah that had
Neil Gaiman and Ramsay Campbell and you
know all those all those type of people
that have that wrote Lovecraftian type
right take off so like you know later on
but I always feel like if you're going
to adapt a Lovecraft story directly um I
always liked the approach of like I
don't know you can do a modern
adaptation like I said look it in the
mouth of madness which we very
Lovecraftian but it wasn't directly
based on a Lovecraft story and if that's
the direction you're gonna go if you
wanted to be set in the modern era then
that's what you should do yeah I feel
like if you're going to adapt a story
directly then you should probably set it
at the time that it was written because
that's one thing I really like about you
know the HP Lovecraft Historical Society
here they made like Call of Cthulhu and
they made whisper in the darkness
and they said it in those days in those
days and actually Call of Cthulhu they
said it so it looked like a silent movie
but yeah actually and it also is kind of
like excitement hair kind of crossbred
with King Kong yeah and it was really
awesome and I thought that was like a
really cool like aesthetic choice it
really gave that whole Lovecraftian vibe
the same vibe that I get when I read one
of his stories so you know I feel like
that's kind of a cool thing to do I
think that's why I probably think like
the you know this
I liked the wraparound segments of this
a lot because it was set in the 30s you
know with Jeffrey Combs playing HP
Lovecraft
and I liked that whole aesthetic some of
the other ones like maybe that's why I
didn't like the third one as much
because it was set in the present day
and to me it just didn't have crafts
kind of yeah ajik and somehow love
crafts in this occult library with the
Necronomicon being inspired to write
these three stories right and some of
these stories are happening in
Lovecraft's future yeah because they
would be they would have to be yeah cuz
you know I mean I'm the second segment I
had a hard time like because it was I
guess the the part that was said in the
modern day and then part of it was that
like in 20 years before although in like
earlier than that like some of it looked
like the 50s but I couldn't figure out
like what time period it was supposed to
be out of all the moments a day gone
well yeah Dagon's if it was the best
Lovecraft even even like the black and
white ones you're talking about that was
an accurate depiction yeah I still think
Dagon is better than those I'd rather
watch Dagon than this well yeah like I
said
Dagon kind of has everything has
everything an entertaining movie it has
a lot of gore it has a lot of action
great music sounds yeah really good
soundtrack but it is always beautiful
but it is also really reminiscent of an
actual Lovecraft store yeah so I think
they really got it on the mark right
there right but uh you know this one
like I said if you like Lovecraft if you
like anthology type movies then probably
you should check this one out if you
haven't seen it and like I said I love
Jeffrey Combs so yeah I'm gonna see
pretty much anything he's in I don't
care
hey just good job but yeah so anyway
that'll do it for our Lovecraftian
inspired movie retrospective works in it
[ __ ] I've had too much coffee remember
if you like the show to like share
subscribe with all your friends and
share on all your social media cuz it
really helps us out a lot
if you'd like to financially support the
show you can go to our patreon page
which is patreon.com slash 13 o'clock
podcast or you can go to our blog which
is 13 o'clock podcast wordpress.com and
there's a link in the sidebar to a
paypal account actually I forgot to show
look at this you guys I got this at
Barnes & Noble like yeah a while back
the goal of creb look at look at how
beautiful that is it was only I think
this was what 15 bucks
yeah something like that and this has
everything of us and silver yeah on the
side and it's got like a little purple
yeah you know bookmark type ribbon there
that's almost everything is written
right it is everything everything's be
complete Oh gage P Lovecraft yeah so
this was like actually a really good
deal I don't know if they're still
selling it it burns ennoble I just got
it in the front of Barnes & Noble cupola
yeah at the mall yeah yeah yeah what was
it the mall well yeah
so that'll do it for this installment be
sure to check out our regular episodes
every Tuesday and our movie reviews
every Friday until next time bye